[Música]
en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy valentina torre
sánchez y es un gusto acompañarlos en
esta ocasión iniciamos en reino unido
donde investigadores de la universidad
de cambridge lograron alterar el tipo de
sangre de tres riñones de donantes lo
que permitiría aumentar la cantidad de
órganos disponibles para transplantes
puntualmente la investigación hace que
los riñones de diferentes tipos de
sangre se hagan compatibles si la sangre
alterada pasa a ser tipo o que es el
tipo de sangre universal se trata de un
avance importante especialmente para
grupos étnicos minoritarios que tienen
menos probabilidades de ser compatibles
con la mayoría de los órganos donados
las personas de grupos étnicos
minoritarios en promedio esperan un año
más para recibir un trasplante de riñón
que las personas con ascendencia
caucásica es otro motivo por lo que esta
avance es fantástico el procedimiento
requiere el uso de una máquina de
perfusión normotérmica un dispositivo
que se con recta al riñón donado y hace
pasar sangre oxigenada a través del
órgano así se preserva mejor luego con
la misma máquina se hace circular la
sangre infundida con enzimas según el
servicio nacional de salud del reino
unido- entre 2020 y 2021 sólo el 9 por
ciento de las donaciones de órganos
provino de minorías étnicas mientras que
constituyen hasta un 33 por ciento de
quienes requieren un trasplante
continuamos en australia donde un equipo
de ingenieros biomédicos de la
universidad de nueva gales del sur
desarrolló una tela inteligente que se
parecería a un músculo artificial los
expertos mostraron su flexibilidad para
transformarse con modelos de una
mariposa y una flor hechos de este
textil
tenemos muchas aplicaciones para nuestra
tecnología podemos usar nuestra
tecnología para hacer robots blandos
bioinspirados que pueden cambiar la
forma para adaptarse a los entornos
circundantes para búsqueda y rescate
para incendios forestales o edificios
derrumbados también podemos usar nuestro
textil parecido a un músculo artificial
suave para hacer prendas de compresión
inteligentes que pueden ayudar a mejorar
la circulación sanguínea lo podemos
hacer un dispositivo portátil suave para
levantar a las personas o ayudar a las
personas con discapacidad a caminar de
nuevo el material cambiado de forma
velozmente y puede levantar o resistir
objetos de hasta 192 veces su peso las
llamadas fibras musculares artificiales
se construyeron a partir de largos tubos
de silicona
del líquido y luego se manipularon
hidráulicamente con una jeringa cuando
hablaban de prendas de compresión los
investigadores mostraron prototipos que
pulsaba en un dedo un antebrazo
proporcionando una terapia de masaje
para aliviar el dolor o mejorar la
circulación sanguínea de la forma en que
nuestro tejido funciona es similar a los
movimientos biológicos de los humanos
cuando reciben presión hidráulica tienen
tensión pero cuando la presión
hidráulica se reduce tienen
contracciones esto significa que podemos
controlar que el músculo tenga
elongación o expansión o contracción
según lo que se requiera
finalizamos con una empresa emergente
llamada lumi rítmica que desarrolló un
software con inteligencia artificial que
crea un modelo realista del rostro de
las personas para entrar en el metaverso
en lugar de los avatares animados
comúnmente disponibles hasta ahora
y listo nuestro primer producto es un
sistema de escaneo 3d de escritorio que
está detrás mío y que sólo usa tabletas
y teléfonos inteligentes básicos just
usen como red y tablets annan
smartphones
en aquí alguna configuración
cuidadosamente diseñada que nos permite
lograr prácticamente la misma captura de
la apariencia de la piel de muy alta
calidad junto con la captura de la forma
entre este lo que nos permite crear
representaciones faciales humanas muy
realistas
los algoritmos que usa esta tecnología
permiten separar la reflectancia del
rostro en componentes que se analizan
por separado y así se modela una
representación facial mucho más realista
los responsables aseguran que los
resultados son representaciones ultras
realistas creadas en minutos y que
podrán beneficiar múltiples entornos la
compañía va a probar la tecnología con
empresas de juegos belleza y publicidad
para implementar la más ampliamente
nuestros objetivos son poder ir más allá
del rostro y lograr todo el cuerpo
humano crear un avatar completo y
realista una vez que esto suceda
podremos impactar el mundo de la moda o
la ropa que te gustaría probarte en un
espacio virtual del space así llegamos
al final de este espacio a ustedes les
agradecemos su sintonía y los invitamos
a ampliar todo nuestro contenido en
nuestra web france24 puntocom
más
[Música]